depuis le 20 avril le gouvernement du
québec autorise les activités de
courtage dites prioritaires pour la
prise de possession d'une propriété ou
le relogement d'une personne avant le 31
juillet tout cela bien sûr à certaines
conditions
caroline champagne vice présidente à
l'organisme d'autoréglementation du
courtage immobilier du québec bonsoir
madame champagne
bonsoir est-ce qu'on crée un goulot
décrypte d'étranglement d'ici le 31
juillet que des transactions ne puisse
pas se faire à temps mais en fait loi c
est qu est qu il a pour mission pour une
émission mais de protéger le public est
effectivement pris est préoccupé par la
situation actuelle qui pourrait
occasionner une crise du réchauffement
alors c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
nombreuses représentations auprès du
gouvernement pour s'assurer justement
que toutes les personnes qui ont besoin
de se relocaliser de se re logique plus
le faire du bbc d'amendé
deux courtiers immobiliers - quelles
sont les règles en ce moment qui
s'applique sur les transactions
immobilières
mais en fait actuellement des activités
de courtage immobilier sont permises
comme par exemple les mises en marché de
propriété perny présenté une première
chance également permis toutefois le
gouvernement a décidé de limiter la
possibilité de faire des limites des
visites pardon en personne et puis on a
posé trois conditions donc tout d'abord
la première c'est que il doit s'agir de
transactions prioritaires pour la libye
pour une prise de possession ou de
relocalisation avant le 31 juillet
deuxièmement les transactions doivent
les mises en marche i doivent avoir été
effectuée avant le 20 avril
et troisièmement il doit y avoir le
respect de conditions sanitaires
strictes et loyers plus à développer un
outil un guide de pratique pour
justement s'assurer que toutes ces
conditions imposées par le gouvernement
soient restés et par les courtiers qui
accompagne le public dans le cadre de
leurs transactions immobilières ont par
exemple il ya une attestation de
transactions prioritaires qui doivent
être signés par les acheteurs qui sont
intéressés une déclaration également
relatives aux coronavirus doit être
aussi autant par les vendeurs que par
les visiteurs les arpentage
m les inspecteurs qui aurait à visiter
la propriété a pas être présent sur
place que une seule personne à la fois
peu visités on doit aussi nettoyer
toutes les surfaces il pourrait toucher
donc un évident de conditions comme
celles-là font partie de notre guide
qu'on a développés comment savoir si
notre transaction est prioritaire de
transactions qui sont prévues d'ici au
31 juillet ou qui vise à lèvres laquelle
la viande d'ici au 31 juillet par
exemple j'ai vendu mes repères bon et je
dois me re qu'alizé où j'ai décidé de ne
pas renouveler mon gars et je dois me re
localiser avant le 31 juillet c'est
considéré comme étant une transaction
prioritaires l'ouest et qui souffrait
par ailleurs que toutes les propriétés
qui sont mises en vente que ce soit seul
avant le 20 avril ou après le 20 avril
puisse être visité justement pour
permettre à toutes ces personnes qui
sont à la recherche de logement ou de
maisons de pouvoir le faire devoir
visiter en toute sécurité
est ce que fait paul fut pas le moment
de mettre en avant d'une propriété
oui absolument c'est possible de mettre
en vente toutefois l'aspect visite doit
se faire de manière virtuelle amorphe
on doit et courtiers doivent faire faire
des visites de manière virtuelle et
doivent avoir des échanges de manière
virtuelle également avec leurs clients
en nous ce que l'on se sent pas vraiment
fait pas dire que c'est pas pareil puis
c'est pour ce qu' on ne fait ces
compresseurs présentation plus
finalement afin de nous assurer le cul
toutes les visites puis celle de toutes
les maisons qui sont sans vendre
actuellement plus être et visiter en
personne et en toute sécurité en
fonction des règles et qui sont elles
qui sont celles qui ont établi le
gouvernement force et c'est vraiment ce
que l'on souhaite que soit mise en
oeuvre commence à tutoyer pour le
courtage commercial location-vente
visite de locaux commerciaux et mais en
fait malheureusement c'est encore un
limité aux moyens technologiques car il
n'est pas possible pour un cours tir
mais sa commercialisation d un local une
bâtisse commerciale
alors que l'on sait actuellement de
nombreuses entreprises vivre des
difficultés importantes alors ce serait
aussi très souhaitable qu'elle puisse de
pouvoir bénéficier du service du
courtage commercial visitez pour sur la
location ou l'achat d'une propriété pour
se relocaliser un peu importe le délai
peu importe que ce soit avant ou après
le 31 juillet est ce qu'un locataire
habitant un immeuble en vente en ce
moment peut interdire la visite de son
logement en disant je crains lakovic 19
mai dans la mesure où est ce que cette
personne a brisé son propriétaire fait
qu'il ne n'avais pas l'intention de
renouveler son bail
il doit donné accès à son logement
évidemment si ta compagnie ce le
propriétaire est accompagné d'un court
si le courtier veillera aux principes et
le des conditions sanitaires imposées
par le gouvernement qui se trouvent dans
notre guide
donc on va s'assurer qu'un instrument
que investisseurs à la fois que toutes
les surfaces soient nettoyées que le
vendeur de même que l'occupant soit quoi
l'intérieur du logement au moment de la
visite pour assurer justement que toute
souffrance en toute sécurité
un vendeur de 60 ans et plus qui doit se
relever avant le 31 juillet peut-il
faire visiter sa maison et faire des
visites lui-même oui il pub fr
celui qui vend à sa propriété et de
voyages à l'extérieur de sa propriété
lors des visites et seulement qu'une
personne à la fois pour revisiter avec
le courtier mais c'est la même règle qui
s'applique pour n'importe qui même chose
s'ils souhaitent aller visiter un
logement ou maison propriété il est
maintenant il peut le faire mais en
suivant tamale les conditions qui sont
établies par le gouvernement que les
courtisaient avoir testé le concept de
visites libres fait formellement
interdit toujours est formellement
interdit effectivement
donc comme je peux et les visites ont
lieu sur un second rendez vous doivent
être prévus à l'avancé c'est ce manque
une visite à la fois qui est peint
depuis une seule personne à la fois dans
la propriété avec le courtier bien alors
on s'informe sur votre site web
notamment et pour les règles et le guide
dont vous avez parlé
merci madame champagne merci pourquoi